IAN NI-LEWIS: Welcome,
audio diehards.
We're so happy to
have you here.
It's great to see that more
than 10 or 15 people would
like to hear about high
performance audio on Android.
We were running bets.
So I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
I'm the developer relations
contact for audio.
If you send audio questions to
our developers support email,
probably I will answer them.
But today, it's my great
pleasure to introduce a couple
friends of mine from the
engineering team, Glenn Kasten
and Raph Levien, who have
actually done a huge amount of
work in the last couple of years
to set the standard for
Android audio and
make it better.
And you're going to be hearing
today some happy stories and
some sad stories just
to prep you on that.
But believe me, these guys have
advanced to state of the
art for Android audio more than
anyone else and also Raph
did some, too.
I know you were going
to call me on that.
Anyway, I start stop talking.
Let's go ahead and welcome Glenn
Kasten to begin High
Performance Audio on Android.
[APPLAUSE]
GLENN KASTEN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Glenn Kasten.
I'm on the Android audio team,
and my job is to provide great
Android audio performance.
I work with our OEMs and silicon
chip vendors to help
them build devices that have
really great audio.
And my goal is to provide
you developers
really top notch audio.
That's what I'm working on.
I know what you want to hear.
So let me disappoint you first,
as Ian was hinting at.
We're not quite there yet.
But the good news is we are
definitely making progress.
So today, we're going to tell
you the story of what we've
been doing so far and how you
can take advantage of the work
we've done so far.
We're also going to tell you
about what's coming up in the
future in terms of our
performance goals.
Now, performance could mean a
lot of different things to
different people.
But today, we're
going to focus.
We're going to focus among all
these different things on just
one area, which is
output latency.
If you're interested in input
latency or other kinds of
audio performance, definitely
check us out at office hours.
Actually, check us out at office
hours anyway even if
you're not interested
in something else.
We want to talk to you about
the other things.
But today, we're just going to
focus on output latency,
because that's the area we've
made the most progress over
the last two years.
So with regards to latency, this
is a mock slide showing
where we were, where we are now,
and where we want to be.
But it doesn't really tell the
whole story of why did it take
us on to get to this point,
what's the work that's been
done, what's the work ahead,
what can you do as audio
developers?
So today, we're going
to really get into
this in more detail.
Explaining that is a really
big job, and so I brought
along my buddy, Raph, who's
going to help me out.
RAPH LEVIEN: Hi, my name is Raph
Levien, and I work on the
Android Frameworks team.
You may know me--
Glenn, next slide--
from such features
as Inconsolata,
the programming font.
Now, my day job--
next slide-- my day job
is font and text
rendering on Android.
But in my spare time, I've
been building a software
emulation of the Yamaha
DX7 synthesizer.
I actually brought the original
with me today.
But I've been building software
emulation, and I
really wanted the emulation
to be as beautiful as the
original synthesizer.
And in fact, that's
how I met Glenn.
I was trying to figure out
why I couldn't get better
performance running my synth
engine on Android.
And Glenn's name kept popping
up in email threads about
audio latency.
GLENN KASTEN: And I fixed
all of his problems.
RAPH LEVIEN: Well, let's
just tell the story.
It's a good story.
GLENN KASTEN: When Raph first
contacted me, we were already
looking into audio
performance.
The Android Frameworks team,
the graphics team, and the
apps team, they were all looking
into performance, too,
mostly on the touch side and
on the graphic side.
But the audio team was
definitely looking into
performance, too.
And overall, we were calling
this Project Butter.
We were all thinking, how
can we make things
more fast, more smooth?
But when it came to audio,
there was really only one
thing that everybody
knew for certain.
The latency was just
too darn high--
no question about that.
RAPH LEVIEN: I think I was
in same situation as
a lot of you guys.
I was writing a musical
instrument that was supposed
to be responsive.
But I could hear a noticeable
delay between the time I hit a
key and the time my
app responded.
Latency is the delay as a signal
passes through the
system, from your
app to sound.
Some musicians, like organists,
are trained to deal
with high latencies if
it's consistent.
But most people are sensitive
to latencies greater than
about 20 milliseconds.
And some can't deal with
any latency at all.
Any percussionists
or singers here?
I wasn't asking for
zero latency.
I would've been happy with 10,
maybe even 20 milliseconds.
But I was hearing noticeable
delays-- over 100 milliseconds
on some devices.
This story is about how Glenn
helped me get my app's latency
down to where it became a
truly playable synth.
As you'll see, it took us some
work on both the Android side
and the app side.
So as we tell the story, we're
going to keep a running to do
list of things we've done,
things we still need to do,
and things you need to do in
your app to get low latency
audio to work.
GLENN KASTEN: Now, I know you're
all dragging out your
notebooks now to start writing
down this to do list.
But don't worry.
We are going to show the to
do list at the end also.
The first thing, the most
important thing, and you're
going to see this throughout
the whole talk.
It's going to keep coming up
over and over and over again,
is measure everything.
We do it, and we hope
you will too.
RAPH LEVIEN: Before you can
make changes to improve
performance, you have to have
an objective measurement of
how bad it is.
Otherwise, you're
flying blind.
GLENN KASTEN: My brother, Steven
was a musician, and he
also built electronics.
And I told them about
my project working
here on audio latency.
And he encouraged me to get an
oscilloscope, because, lets
face it, real engineers
have scopes.
So even though I worked at
Google, I do have a budget.
So I got the cheapest
oscilloscope I could find.
And it's definitely not anything
fancy, not good for
high speed communications.
But it was certainly perfectly
adequate for audio.
RAPH LEVIEN: The scope makes
it possible to get precise
measurements, but the really
tricky part is getting
accurately and reproducable
measurements, especially if we
want to hopefully someday make
this part of the Android
compatibility testing suite.
We also need to make sure we
isolate audio output latency
from the other sources of delay
in a system, like the
audio input or the
touch panel.
Glenn came up with a cool
way to do that.
GLENN KASTEN: So besides the
scope, another great tool that
I love is the LED, or lighting
emitting diode.
I remember discovering the LED
when I was 12 years old, and
I've been in love
ever since then.
I think one of the greatest
things about a phone is the
notification LED.
It's so useful, so fast, and
yet it's really underused.
I can measure audio latency with
an LED, a photo diode,
and an oscilloscope.
Basically, you just turn on the
LED at the same time as
your application is outputting
audio data.
Then measure the difference in
time between when you can
detect the light from the LED
and when you can detect the
audio signal.
That difference is latency.
So my brother was into
electronics.
I was, too, especially
when I was younger.
So I brought back my electronics
kit, and I started
with a bread board design.
This is it.
Later on, one of our hardware
engineers, Clinton, helped me
out, and he made be a real live
printed circuit board,
which you can see here.
No, it does not actually have
a red border on it.
That's just a highlight.
And here's the result with
an oscilloscope.
Basically, the yellow trace is
the light detector from the
LED to the photo diode.
And the blue trace
is the audio.
I unfortunately can't really
get into exact numbers.
They don't let me here.
But let's just say that it
was a really big number--
way too big.
So let's talk about why.
RAPH LEVIEN: Latency in the real
world is complex, but in
software, it generally boils
down to one thing--
chains of buffers.
GLENN KASTEN: Here's a typical
un-optimized audio pipeline,
the kind that I found when I
first started looking at this
problem a couple years ago.
As you can see from this
diagram, we have four buffers
of 1,024 frames or 23
milliseconds each at 44 kilohertz.
And that's just in the audio
hardware abstraction layer, or
HAL, and the kernel driver.
That doesn't even count the
buffers in the media server,
in the DSP, in the mixer,
certainly not in the
application.
RAPH LEVIEN: In case that's
not clear, that's a huge
amount of buffering.
There's 92 milliseconds of
latency right there.
If you're an audio developer,
you've got to be asking
yourself, why are the
buffers so big?
And why are there
so many of them?
GLENN KASTEN: So there is a
technical explanation, which
we're going to get into today.
But I also think there's a
social explanation, and we'll
hint at it throughout the
talk today, too, also.
RAPH LEVIEN: Let's start
with the technical.
It has to do with power
consumption.
The larger the interval between
CPU core wake ups, the
less power needed.
GLENN KASTEN: As you
know, mobile
phones run on batteries.
Batteries have limited life.
So the CPU switches on and off
very, very frequently between
normal state and low
power state.
The size of each audio buffer
basically puts a lower bound
on the amount of time that the
CPU can be asleep before it
has to wake up again and process
the next audio buffer.
To a certain extent, that
defines both your power
consumption and your
potential latency.
And if you want to reduce power,
you have to add more
buffering so the CPU doesn't
have to wake up as often.
As for the social component, my
theory is that buffering is
just a really quick and easy
way to fix audio glitches.
If you hear a glitch, almost
always it seems that if you
just make your buffers bigger,
it'll make it go away.
And unless you actively police
buffer sizes, they're going to
continue to increase
over time.
RAPH LEVIEN: And other than a
devoted band of developers,
like you and me, it didn't
seem like anyone in the
Android world has had a
compelling incentive to reduce
buffer sizes.
I think a lot of us suspected
that there wasn't actually any
particularly good reason
for latency to be
as high as it was.
Maybe the buffers were just
bigger than they had to be.
GLENN KASTEN: Sounds
simple, huh?
Well, this turned out
to be a pretty easy
hypothesis to disprove.
I tried an experiment.
Remember, we started with
four buffers of 23
milliseconds each.
So I just said, OK, let's
make them smaller.
Let's have fewer of them.
Instead of four of 23, I went
down to two of 12 or 13, then
two of six.
And eventually, on one device, I
was even able to get down to
two buffers of three
milliseconds.
I didn't try to change the
system architecture or
anything else, just
the buffers.
And amazingly, it worked.
Audio still played.
The latency went down
dramatically.
I was done.
RAPH LEVIEN: You were done?
Are you sure?
GLENN KASTEN: Well, you knew the
talk wouldn't be over now.
It did work most of the time.
But every once in awhile,
I heard a
click, a pop, an underrun.
And this really did make
me sick to my stomach.
I know it's hard for me to
show it today, but I felt
awful every time I heard
those clicks.
And I knew this was not
going to be so easy.
RAPH LEVIEN: And I've have
a lot of experience with
underruns myself.
I heard them on my synthesizer
when I had
too many voices playing.
I think it's worth talking a
little bit about the methods
we used to detect them.
GLENN KASTEN: Definitely.
But first, let's listen to
some underruns together.
Don't worry.
It's only a few seconds, but we
want all of us to use the
same terminology.
In this clip, we're going
to first hear
a few shorter clicks.
Followed by some longer
dropouts.
They're all underruns.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLENN KASTEN: Did everybody
hear those?
We're a little worried, because
in a room this large,
there's quite a bit of reverb.
And what Raph and I have found
is that when you're listening
with speakers, and especially
in a room with a lot of
reverb, that it's harder to
hear those underruns.
So that's one reason why we
personally prefer to listen
for audio problems
with headphones.
Or as you'll soon see, we
actually like to look for them
visually, too.
So we heard the underruns.
Let's look at them visually.
I mentioned we were going to.
Here is a long 15 millisecond
underrun in the audio editor
tool called Audacity.
RAPH LEVIEN: Those long
underruns are
pretty easy to spot.
GLENN KASTEN: Yeah, but
unfortunately, I wasn't just
hearing those long ones.
I was also hearing
short clicks.
And those were really hard
to find with Audacity.
Here's one here.
This is only 64 frames, I
believe, which is 1 and 1/2
milliseconds, I think at either
44 or 48 kilohertz.
And it took me a long time
to find this one.
I just didn't have
the patience to
keep looking for these.
RAPH LEVIEN: Yeah, they're
tricky to spot in time domain.
But in the frequency domain,
underruns pop out.
Here's that same area after
a Fourier transform.
See those spikes on the right?
Those regularly spaced
spikes mean trouble.
You use Frequency Domain View,
and then you can binary search
to help zoom in on the
shortest underruns.
GLENN KASTEN: So let's
get back to my
problem, my latency problem.
I notice that when I reduced
buffer sizes, the latency went
down, but I also was hearing
these clicks.
RAPH LEVIEN: So we were wrong.
The buffers were just about as
big as they had to be to keep
the audio from glitching.
They weren't just about
saving power.
They were also keeping
it clean.
GLENN KASTEN:
GLENN KASTEN: Now we needed to
figure out why, why those
glitches were happening.
And while I was working on the
system problem, it turned out
Raph had also collected some
data of his own, which we're
going to look at right now.
RAPH LEVIEN: That's right.
Isn't this beautiful?
Maybe I should take a couple
of minutes and explain what
this plot is showing.
What I was measuring is the
start time and the end time of
every open SL callback.
This is by far the most useful
information you can log.
At first, I was doing this to
profile how long my own code
took to run.
But I ended up learning
a lot about how the
system worked as well.
So let's start with a little
bit of background.
GLENN KASTEN: So we used Open
SLES from Cronos Group.
And in our implementation, the
audio runs on a separate
thread inside of your
application process.
And the thread runs in a tight
little loop that looks a lot
like a helix, like a spring.
Each time through the loop, our
Open SLES implementation
will call your buffer completion
callback handler to
generate the next buffer.
RAPH LEVIEN: The time between
two successive callbacks is
the cycle time.
GLENN KASTEN: And ideally,
the cycle time should be
consistent.
In part, it should be equal
to the size of one buffer.
RAPH LEVIEN: So in an ideal
world, if we plotted the
callback time against the
expected callback time, we'd
see a perfectly straight line.
Of course, nothing is perfect.
If we plot the time that
callbacks actually arrive
against the expected time of
arrival, we're going to see
some deviations.
Each little squiggle in this
graph represents a deviation
from the ideal callback
timing.
But to tell the truth, I have
a hard time using this graph
to tell exactly how bad
the deviation is.
Instead, I like to view the
data a little differently.
Instead of looking at callback
times, I just look at how
early or late each
callback arrived.
Here, the y-axis is a
measurement of deviation from
ideal timing amplified, so
we can see it better.
You can think this as
a measurement of
the system's jitter.
I've also changed the
x-axis a bit.
Instead of being measured in
time, it's simply a count of
how many callbacks
have arrived.
That way, I can compare the
jitter of two different
systems, even if they
have different
callback cycle times.
GLENN KASTEN: So now that we
know how we're measuring and
displaying this jitter, let's
look at some real world data.
RAPH LEVIEN: So this is taken
from a build of Ice Cream
Sandwich that's close to
the one Glenn used.
GLENN KASTEN: It looks
interesting.
But why does it slope down
and to the right?
RAPH LEVIEN: That downward trend
is actually a difference
in timing between the audio
clock and the system clock.
So let's look at the
corrected version.
Now remember an ideal system
would show all zeros on the
y-axis, meaning that every
buffer completion callback had
arrived exactly on time.
Of course, no system
is perfect.
So what you'd expect to see in a
good, real world system is a
tight cluster of values right
around the zero mark.
GLENN KASTEN: It looks kind of
like that, mostly, at least
the green part.
RAPH LEVIEN: Yeah, but you also
see a lot of callbacks
arriving five or 10
milliseconds late.
That's manageable, even
if it's not ideal.
GLENN KASTEN: But I don't like
those red ones there,
especially at the beginning--
those outliers.
They look like 20, 30,
35 milliseconds late.
RAPH LEVIEN: Dang.
That's with those giant buffers
were for, not just to
save power, but to cover for the
fact that the audio system
was delivering some of these
callbacks really late.
GLENN KASTEN: Now, this really
bothered me, because Android
is not a real time system.
But we had configured the thread
priorities for audio to
be nice little minus 19 for the
system mixer and then nice
little minus 16 for application
threads.
And the schedule really should
not have been doing this.
It just didn't make sense.
Just to give you background on
nice values, basically, if
this pie is all the available
CPU time, than numerically low
or nice values, like minus 19
and minus 16 should get more
of the CPU pie.
And they should be scheduled
on a regular cadence, not
waiting 10s of milliseconds
and certainly not 35.
RAPH LEVIEN: So those jitter
outliers who saw in the
previous slide, those are going
to cause underruns.
What was happening in the
system to cause them?
GLENN KASTEN: That's exactly
what I wanted to know.
So I dug a lot deeper.
Now, I'm not a Linux Kernel
expert, but I do have a
background in real time
operating systems.
I used to write real
time Kernels.
And so I feel very comfortable
jumping in and doing some
system measurements at
the current level.
At the time, we didn't have the
sys trace tool, which you
may have heard of.
And I didn't know about the
existing Linux tools for
tracing, like f trace.
So instead, I just built
my own custom
context switch tracer.
This is what it looked like.
Basically, every time there was
a context switch, it would
log information about
this context
switch into a ring buffer.
The information was basically
the next thread about to run
and whatever was the current
system monotonic time.
Then what I would do is
I would play audio.
And at the same time, I would
run my context switch tracer.
And whenever I heard a glitch,
I would look and see what was
happening in the system at
the time of that glitch.
And it took me a long,
long time.
But eventually, I found
what looked to me to
be the smoking gun.
RAPH LEVIEN: This an excerpt of
Glenn's context switch log.
The first 12 lines are exactly
what we want to see.
The playback thread and the
audio track thread wake up, do
their thing, and then go back to
sleep on a regular cadence.
Those last four lines
look wrong.
GLENN KASTEN: And by the
way, this is real data.
All the data you're seeing
here today is real.
This was the smoking gun.
So let's look at that same data
as a sequence diagram.
RAPH LEVIEN: You can see the
pattern here-- first, playback
runs, then audio track
runs, and then
lather, rinse, and repeat.
But what happens near the
end of the trace?
Right when the playback thread
was supposed to wake up,
another task gets scheduled
instead.
This is in spite of the fact
that the audio has a higher
priority-- nice minus 19.
How could that have happened?
GLENN KASTEN: Well, it all comes
down to a Linux Kernel
module, which is called
the completely fair
scheduler, or CFS.
Earlier, I showed this
slide showing nice
values in the CPU pie.
If you look really closely,
there's a very important
caveat there.
It says huge oversimplification.
Nice values are not
a quota system.
RAPH LEVIEN: The CFS scheduler
allocates CPU time fairly and
proportionally to the nice
level in the long term.
But it does not guarantee
wake up time.
In these two timing diagrams,
the dark bars ar e audio
threads, and the light bars
are other threads.
To CFS, the top and bottom
diagrams are completely
equivalent, but to an
audio programmer,
they're completely different.
We want the pattern on top.
GLENN KASTEN: So I tried
working around CFS.
CFS has a lot of tuning
parameters.
The most important one is the
scheduling interval or
scheduling quantum.
There are other parameters,
such as how often it will
check for fairness.
And when I turned those down to
really small numbers, I was
able to get rid of most of
the audio underruns.
But it turned out that all that
messing around with CFS
parameter used a
lot more power.
And even worse, it caused the
overall system throughput for
non-audio threads to
go down because of
excessive context switching.
And worst of all, it didn't even
solve my audio underrun
problem completely.
It just reduced the frequency.
RAPH LEVIEN: The most effective
tweaks just reduce
the time slice that each
thread gets before the
scheduler reevaluates.
It doesn't change the core
algorithm, which is to try to
be fair to every thread.
But in our case, we don't
want to be fair.
We want audio to go to the front
of the line every time.
Reducing the time slice just
causes more content switching,
which uses more power.
GLENN KASTEN: So from my real
time operating system
background working on kernels,
I knew about fixed priority
scheduling--
it's a very old concept--
and I desperately wanted
to use it.
The basic idea is that you
always run the highest
priority ready to run task,
no matter what.
And if you assign your
priorities correctly and
appropriately, your system will
work, no matter what.
RAPH LEVIEN: In Linux, this
means using a scheduling
policy called SCHED FIFO.
A lot of audio developers know
about SCHED FIFO, and we know
that there are plenty of Linux
desktop programs that use it,
and Android apps that try.
But it doesn't work
in Android.
On Ice Cream Sandwich,
it did nothing.
And in Jelly Bean, been asking
for SCHED FIFO causes thread
creation to fail.
GLENN KASTEN: That's because
we disabled it
for user mode threads.
RAPH LEVIEN: Why did
you do that?
GLENN KASTEN: Not me.
Our assistant team was afraid of
denial of service, because
basically, one errant SCHED FIFO
thread could hog the CPU
and take down the
whole system.
And yet we still handled
our callbacks on time.
So I went back to our system
team, and I tried to make
another case for SCHED FIFO.
I showed them slides with
numbers and statistics and
power measurements.
And this time, they sent me a
buddy, a Kernel expert named
Dima, who you may
run into today.
He's here.
Dima helped me navigate the
issue and figure out how to
mitigate the denial
of service risk.
The answer turned out to be
based on a Kernel feature that
actually Google started working
on several years ago
in 2006 called Control
Groups, or C Groups.
RAPH LEVIEN: Cgroups is
a system for resource
accounting.
You can use it for all kinds
of things, like setting CPU
and memory quotas for different
processes or
charging for cloud servers
by the CPU hour.
In the case of Android, it lets
us prevent audio threads
from ever exceeding
its CPU budget.
And that mitigates the denial
of service attack.
GLENN KASTEN: So in the end, the
system team did agree we
could run audio threads at a
fixed priority if we used
Cgroups to stay within the
budget they gave us, which was
a whopping 5% of the CPU.
Later on, we got that budget
increased, but actually
starting with only 5% turned
out to be a really good
constraint for us.
It forced us to reduce the CPU
footprint of the audio system.
RAPH LEVIEN: Keep that number
in mind for later.
For now, it's important to
understand that SCHED FIFO
priority only applies to threads
that are created by
the audio system.
You can't do it for
your own threads.
So that means if you want the
lowest latency, you need to
run your audio code on
an audio thread.
In practice, that means you need
to do your processing in
a buffer callback.
That means writing your
sound engine in C++
and using Open SLES.
And of course, not doing your
engine in Java means you don't
have to worry about pauses from
the Garbage Collector.
GLENN KASTEN: But you are still
subject to the audio
Cgroup budget.
We'll discuss budgets
later on.
But first, Raph, show us
some more numbers.
RAPH LEVIEN: Sure.
Let's see how well that change
to SCHED FIFO worked.
This is a little misleading.
But the build I measured
contains some other fixes
besides SCHED FIFO.
But it's essentially accurate.
You can see that where Ice Cream
Sandwich jitter was all
over the place, on Jelly Bean,
it's clumped in a tight band
right around zero.
The problem is solved.
GLENN KASTEN: Woo-hoo!
Well, not so fast.
Remember that in order to get
that reduction in jitter, we
had agreed to a really tight
budget for audio, at the time
only 5% of the CPU.
Unfortunately, when I profiled
the audio subsystem, on some
devices, it took longer than
5% just to run our mixer or
our sample reconverter
and audio effects,
like reverb and EQ.
And it looked like I had a
massive optimization task in
front of me, because we had that
5% for his application.
RAPH LEVIEN: And to be fair,
that subsystem is doing a lot
of work, especially if effects
are turned on.
What was frustrating to
me is that it was work
that I didn't want.
I'm not dependent on any
one sample rate.
I can do my own mixing.
And I spent weeks with a signal
analyzer determining
the exact physical properties of
that synthesizer's digital
to analog converter hardware to
build a precise emulation.
I didn't want to add any
one size fits all
effects on top of that.
GLENN KASTEN: My big aha moment
was when I realized
that pretty much every audio
developer feels the same way,
every developer who's interested
in low latency
audio, anyway.
So instead of trying to optimize
our system audio
path, I just bypassed it.
And I call this the fast path.
Here's how it works.
The top section basically
is running
under the old CFS scheduler.
That includes our normal mixer,
normal track switch,
support resampling, they support
mixing, they support
effects, things like that.
The bottom is the fast path.
And here, the low latency
applications send their audio
directly into the fast mixer,
which then drive the hardware
abstraction layer.
And they all run under the
SCHED FIFO policy.
RAPH LEVIEN: And they're
limited to the
audio budget of 5%.
GLENN KASTEN: Yeah, 5%.
We're actually able to negotiate
that up a little bit
later, but there still
is a budget.
Now remember, earlier we were
talking about power.
And one of the reasons why
buffers were so big was to
reduce the CPU wake
up frequency.
So when we used the low latency
path, it does increase
power consumption.
Fortunately, one of our audio
engineers, our audio tech
lead, Eric, added another
feature called the Deep Buffer
Path, which is used, for
example, music playback when
your phone is in your pocket.
And that is recommended when
you're trying to conserve
power instead of latency.
RAPH LEVIEN: So at this point
in time, I'd been following
Glenn's work pretty closely, I
was very excited to try out
this new fast path.
I had just gotten a shiny new
Nexus 4, so I flashed a build
onto my device, loaded
up my synthesizer,
and nothing, no change.
GLENN KASTEN: No change?
RAPH LEVIEN: Well,
almost no change.
There was some reduction in
latency, but nowhere nearly as
much as I would have liked.
Keep in mind, I'd already made
all of the obvious changes.
I had rewritten my synthesis
engine in C++.
I was running in the open SL
callback, so my code would run
at that same high priority
scheduling.
The obvious conclusion was
that my app was to blame.
So I started profiling.
What I found surprised
me a little bit.
When I looked at my jitter
measurements in the new build,
they were terrible.
I knew Glenn had measured much
better jitter than this in his
build, so I asked him
what was going on.
GLENN KASTEN: I was really
stumped too until I asked Raph
was sample rate he was using,
and he said 44.1, which is
what was used on the Nexus
7 and the Galaxy Nexus.
But it turns out the Nexus 4
runs natively at 48 kilohertz.
RAPH LEVIEN: So my buffers
had to go through
the sample rate converter.
And the sample rate converter
is not on the fast path.
Here's another plot that
shows a related issue.
This isn't as bad as
the first one.
There's only about a five
millisecond variation
in start time here.
But there's something
weird about it.
The stripes in the data make me
think I'm looking at some
kind of periodic process,
not just random noise.
Let's zoom in and see if
we can find a pattern.
GLENN KASTEN: Yeah, that looks
like a pattern to me.
RAPH LEVIEN: It's
pretty regular.
Looks like every 16 buffers,
I get my callback late.
It turns out this was because
of another assumption I had
made that didn't hold
true on the Nexus 4.
I had set my buffer size
to 256, which was
a convenient size.
GLENN KASTEN: What Raph didn't
know at the time was that on
the Nexus 4, our native buffer
size was 240 frames, not 256.
And the greatest common divisor
of those two is--
RAPH LEVIEN: 16.
So that's the next item on your
to do list-- adapt your
buffer size and sample
rate to match what
the system is using.
But how do you know what
buffer size and
sample rate to use?
This is something--
next slide--
this is something that not
only is there variation
between devices, but
it can change even
across Android versions.
In the early days, I struggled
with this a lot.
GLENN KASTEN: I asked Raph what
does he want in the next
version of the Android
audio platform to
better support apps.
And the top of this list was an
API to return this kind of
information--
native buffer size, native
sample rate.
And that shift in
API level 17--
we'll give you a link
to how to do that at
the end of this talk.
RAPH LEVIEN: Here's a snippet
from my app showing how I use
a new sample rate and buffer
size properties to set up my
synth engine.
After I hooked it up, I found
that my synth went from eight
voices to 20.
Finally, I was beating the
30-year-old synthesizer I was
trying to emulate.
Now, let's take a look at an
audible glitch that was really
difficult to track down.
GLENN KASTEN: You're going to
want to pay special attention
to this, because even though
we are going to be using
Raph's code as an example here
today, we've seen similar
issues to this throughout the
audio platform and in other
applications.
And it's really hard
to track down.
RAPH LEVIEN: Here's a plot
of the bug in action.
What you're seeing is the start
and end times of each
buffer callback.
Start time is blue, the
end time is red.
Most of the time the start and
end times are so close that
you almost can't tell
them apart.
What's happening at the
beginning here?
Let's zoom in and
check it out.
Here's a closer look.
The callback started
right on time.
But the end time is
way out there.
It looks like the callback
took about 16
milliseconds to process.
That was enough to cause a
dropout and skip a couple of
buffers, which is what all of
the subsequent callbacks that
recorded is showing up
10 milliseconds late.
GLENN KASTEN: This time
I didn't have an
easy answer for Raph.
But we did have a new tool for
investigating performance
problems, sys trace.
And I know that that
would be good for
investigating this problem.
Sys trace basically collects the
same kind of data that I'd
been collecting with
my manual home brew
context switch recorder.
But it's much easier to use and
has a really attractive
user interface.
We're going to show you a sys
trace first of some good audio
playback and then
a bad sys trace.
First, here's a sys
trace of audio
playback working correctly.
You're going to see every five
milliseconds the fast mixer
thread is the one in red.
It writes out a buffer of audio
to the hardware, then it
wakes up the audio track
thread, which
is part of the client.
And that's the one in green,
which is actually part of your
application.
And that's the thread that's
generating the
next buffer of audio.
Then that computes beautiful
FM sounds for a couple
milliseconds and queues
its buffer, which
goes to the fast mixer.
And then it goes back to sleep
for the next callback.
RAPH LEVIEN: So around
here, we see
something else happening.
The UI thread of the
synthesizer, which is purple,
wakes up and starts computing.
But both the fast mixer and the
audio track threads are
higher priorities.
So when it's time for them
to wake up, the scheduler
suspends the UI thread and lets
the high priority audio
threads run.
So that's good.
No audible glitch here.
GLENN KASTEN: But something
still looks a
little funny here.
The audio track thread looks
like it's been split in two.
Zooming in, we see our UI thread
being scheduled, even
though the audio thread should
be higher priority.
What's going on?
RAPH LEVIEN: Turns out that
when that thread went to
sleep, it was holding a mutex
belonging to the allocator.
Then when the audio callback
went to allocate some memory,
it tried to take the
mutex and blocked.
The only other thread to
run is the UI thread.
So the scheduler wakes it up.
Then it releases the mutex.
And boom-- the audio thread
is runnable again.
It's higher priority, so the
scheduler bumps the UI thread
and lets the audio thread
run to completion.
And we get our buffer
to the mixer with
plenty of time to spare.
This time we were lucky.
GLENN KASTEN: This time.
This wasn't our audible
glitch.
But let's keep looking.
So to help us out, I added a new
sys trace counter for us
for audio called f ready, which
basically is the number
of frames that the application
is providing
to the audio mixer.
You want that to always be
high, high enough for the
mixture to be able to read
the next data from the
application.
And as you can see, most of the
time it's 480, which is
two buffers worth.
But around 1.1 seconds into the
sys trace, we can see it
dropping down to zero.
That's definitely going
to cause a glitch--
no question.
Sys traces is a great tool
for finding these kind of
performance problems.
It's much easier to see them
than to listen for them.
So we have a glitch.
Let's zoom in and see
if we can figure out
exactly what's happening.
At the arrow here, our
user interface
thread, UI, stop running.
And it turns out it's holding
a mutex for a memory
allocation.
Then a whole bunch of
other stuff runs.
And it looks like
UEventObserver--
then the usual.
Fast mixer wakes up.
That wakes up audio track.
But at the arrow, the
audio track tries to
allocate some memory.
And that's going to block.
The UI thread was holding
the mutex
for the memory allocator.
RAPH LEVIEN: Remember the last
time this happened, the UI
thread was the only thing
ready to run.
That's why we were so lucky
there was nothing else for the
kernel to schedule.
So the UI thread did its 30
microseconds worth of work and
unblocked this.
This time, we're not nearly as
lucky, because there's tons of
other threads that want to run,
and the scheduler isn't
smart enough to realize that it
needs to run the UI thread
in order to unblock
the audio thread.
The fast mixer keeps waking up,
but every time it does,
there's no audio.
We were blocked.
So f radio runs out, and
we hear a glitch.
It isn't until 1141 milliseconds
in this trace
that the UI thread finally gets
scheduled again, then
releases a mutex and the
callback can run.
GLENN KASTEN: So this is known
as classic priority inversion.
Basically, it means that a high
priority thread is being
blocked by a lower priority
thread that's holding a
resource, such as a mutex.
And some operating systems have
special logic, especially
in their mutexes, to
handle this case.
But Android is not using
that feature.
RAPH LEVIEN: Here's
the funny thing.
I know about priority
inversions.
I wrote my code very
carefully.
I didn't take any mutexes, or
allocate any memory-- anything
they could block.
Yet the sys trace clearly showed
that the thread was
blocking on the mutex.
Tracing further, I found that
the sprintf call I was using
to generate a log line
was blocking.
GLENN KASTEN: Sprintf
of all things.
So turns out I ran into a
similar issue when I was
working on the audio
fast path.
I had a thread that was calling
into another server by
IPC, inter-process
communication, via binder.
And I knew about classic mutex
priority inversion.
It's a well known issue.
But I didn't think about
the risks of IPC.
RAPH LEVIEN: There are
a bunch of ways to
deal with this problem.
But for this kind of thing,
the simplest is to use
non-blocking techniques.
Don't ever take a mutex on
the audio callback either
explicitly or implicitly through
things like memory
allocation.
GLENN KASTEN: One really simple
among the non-blocking
techniques is, way of avoiding
blocking, is single reader,
single writer ring buffers.
It's really easy to write.
It's simple to understand, and
it works really well for
shuttling either small
or large amounts of
data between threads.
It's commonly used in audio
applications for this reason.
RAPH LEVIEN: Here's how
I used it in my app.
A Java app puts its MIDI bytes
into the ring buffer.
Then the C++ takes
the bytes out.
Checking how many bytes are
available and reading them can
both be done without blocking.
If you weren't in a soft real
time context, you'd probably
use a mutex for this instead.
Do keep in mind, though, that
you still need to use memory
barriers because ARM has a
weekly ordered memory model.
X86 has a total store order,
so if you've implemented a
ring buffer there, you
may not be aware
you need these barriers.
If none of this makes sense
to you, just use
existing correct code.
GLENN KASTEN: And definitely
don't call sprintf.
So let's see what your new graph
looks like now that you
fixed your priority inversion.
RAPH LEVIEN: You bet.
Here it is.
And here it is contracted
for drift.
Now, it's looking clean.
The outliers are gone.
All of the code is strictly
non-blocking.
You do see some weird little
ups and down because of the
power management system changing
the clock frequency,
but that's OK.
Even at the lowest clock
frequency, everything is
happening under two
milliseconds, which is
properly quick.
This might not seem like it
looks better than the previous
plot, but take a look
at the scale.
GLENN KASTEN: That's
a one and a two.
The start times are all
clustered together
the way we like them.
But the end times are still
a little bit weird.
It looks like there's
two bands.
What's going on there?
RAPH LEVIEN: My synth was
doing its computation in
blocks of 64 samples because
it's convenient.
Lots of other libraries
do that too.
Remember, the Nexus 4 buffer
is 240 samples long.
So sometimes we'd compute
256, other times, 192.
That variation explains
the two bands.
This is a nice optimization,
and it took my synth from
about 20 to 30 voices
of polyphony.
After this, I took it the rest
of the way with some old
fashioned cache optimization
and SIMD magic.
So now it's up to 64 voices.
Between Glenn's work on the
system and my optimizations in
this synth engine, my
DX7 app is starting
to look pretty good.
GLENN KASTEN: This is where
things stand for some devices.
That's right.
You knew there had to be a
catch, because as soon as we
started testing this design on
a wider variety of devices,
things started to get
more complicated.
RAPH LEVIEN: The core
of what Glenn did is
valid on every device.
But each device has its own set
of bugs-- power management
issues, driver bugs, or
scheduling snafus.
And each one of those has to
be solved individually.
GLENN KASTEN: If you want to,
catch me during office hours.
I'll tell you some
war stories.
So that's the last thing on my
to do list is to work with our
hardware partners to track down
these crazy kernel driver
and hardware issues that can
affect audio performance.
I'm committed to it.
We're committed to it.
But we're not there yet.
RAPH LEVIEN: But we are moving
in the right direction.
GLENN KASTEN: Yes we are.
RAPH LEVIEN: If you have some
questions or would like to see
more data, come see us in the
Android office hours area
right after this presentation.
GLENN KASTEN: We put together a
website for all of you with
a lot of good audio performance
resources.
So this QR code has a short link
to it, and there's also
the long link there
if you prefer--
codegoogle.com/p
/high-performance-audio.
Lots and lots of resources
there.
And we do plan on continuing
to keep that website up to
date with more things as
we come across some.
So thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
GLENN KASTEN: And again, please
fill the review forms.
And let's talk at
office hours.
RAPH LEVIEN: See you there.
Thank you.